when you ask people how they want to die
the commonest reaction you get is i just
want to go out like a light i want you
know i want to go to bed one day it's
perfectly healthy and just die in the
bed just like that wouldn't it be
wonderful fantastic just you know bang
gone no no awareness no warnings the
fascinating thing is if you go back a
few hundred years that was universally
regarded as the most terrible way to die
really everybody agreed that sudden
unexpected death was the absolute
catastrophe
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is a
medical ethicist and the author of dying
well dr john wyatt welcome to
trigonometry great to be here it's so
good to have you on the show uh we're
going to talk about the cheery subject
of death you're already excited about it
i can tell but before we get into that
uh tell everybody a little bit about
your background who are you how are you
where you are how do you find yourself
here talking to us
yeah my background is as a medic i'm a
baby doctor by training and profession i
worked as a pediatrician and a
specialist in the care of newborn babies
here in central london university
college london
and i'm an academic researcher
i was particularly involved in brain
injury and finding new treatments for
preventing brain injury newborn babies
and then as from my work i got more and
more interested in some of the
fascinating and challenging ethical uh
debates that are going on to do with
medicine and as the advances in
technology and so
i've now retired from the clinical front
line but i'm still very much involved
and engaged in medical ethics and in
technology issues related to technology
including artificial intelligence and
the new challenges which are coming up
down the road but i'm very interested in
dying
not personally well i'm trying to keep
it up there you know but actually to be
honest i'm actually quite fascinated to
know what it feels like i've i've cared
for so many people who've been dying
i've watched people die
and you know one of the weird things
about the modern world is that we've put
dying
out of sight it isn't something we we
talk about it isn't something we
experience and it's a great point it's
something that we don't talk about it's
something that is an absolute taboo
subject in the west
and
it seems to me that over the past 18
months as a pandemic has encroached in
all our lives we've suddenly become a
little bit more aware of our own
mortality and i think we've had a little
bit of a moral crisis would you agree
well i think something in that i think i
think the interesting thing is that uh
particularly what psychoanalysts and and
psychologists say is is that
all of us suffer fundamentally from
death anxiety from
this outrageous discovery that our lives
are going to end
and then we develop psychological
mechanisms to try and
live with that reality and the communist
psychological mechanism is is defense we
deny it we pretend it doesn't happen
it's not gonna happen it doesn't happen
to people like me and i get on with
living with my life and what's happened
in the pandemic is that all of a sudden
that those defense mechanisms have
turned out to be not very good because
we've just been bombarded with these
horrific images haven't we of
of you know mass graves and intensive
care units and weeping relatives and and
watching those statistics and we've
realized actually
it does affect us and and so i think
there is a sort of epidemic of death
anxiety particularly in those early days
of the lockdown
and you know you talk about death
anxiety what are the symptoms of death
anxiety
well i think everybody is is incredibly
different isn't it i mean how
how how do people cope with this sense
of a lot of it is just fear i mean
um
a sense of heart racing you know the
symptoms of fear anxiety
um you know one of the things we've all
got used to is you you're walking along
the street and someone's coming the
other way and you suddenly
you you almost bump into them and i
remember people cowering back and and
with great sort of terror on their faces
that you know you were going to be the
angel of death to them that kind of of
um so so i think fear
i think depression
i i think sleeplessness inability to
sleep um you know there's been an
epidemic of mental health and it comes
out in many many different ways and
tragically also i think broken
relationships abuse
you know a whole litany of things one of
the things is pediatricians
we're aware of it the fact it's actually
an increase in child abuse
going on during the lockdown
but often not recognized because the
normal mechanisms by which these things
became apparent were not there
do you think we we've reacted rationally
to this the fear because i think you're
right when we look around and see how
people react when i see some polling
numbers for example you know 20 percent
of the british public want a permanent
curfew after 10 years
i'm not sure you really you know you're
reacting rationally to this do you think
that as a society
as francis i think it was alluding to
earlier we've kind of wet the bed on
this one a little bit
probably a great deal of bed wetting
going on but um
you know i i think
we we don't know
as human beings we find it incredibly
hard to assess risk
you know so you know in my previous work
as a pediatrician one of the things i
often had to do was to discuss with
parents whether they were going to have
their children vaccinated and
particularly early on in my career it
was about the whooping cough actually
there was there were
there were statistics that one in 300
000 children suffered permanent brain
damage because of a whooping cough
vaccination and i've spent endless hours
of my life
talking to parents who've been agonizing
about you know should i have my child
vaccinated what are the risks and so on
and the problem is of course if you say
if your risk is 100 000 or 185 or what
does that mean you know if i've got a 1
in 85 risk of dying is that something i
should worry about is that something i
should change my life over
you know what if it's one in two and
fifty is that better than one in eighty
five you know i think psychologically we
just can't
access those
those mathematical risks and we don't
know how to translate it into into
living and and this is i think part of
the problem in the pandemic is is how
psychologically we learn to live with
risk and i think that a lot of people
got the i the risk completely out of
our kilter
um so that they felt that by going to
the local shop you know
they they were putting their life at
mortal risk and therefore
and interestingly you know i mean
politically you can see that that boris
and and the the government in those
early days of the lockdown their their
intention was to in stoke fear i mean it
was in order to get people to obey the
lockdown they
they deliberately
stoked these these images about you know
save lives protect the nhs it was
and the the hidden message if you don't
follow the lock down you might die so
there was someone else or killed someone
else and so there was this deliberate
stoking one there of of fears and now
when we say hang on it's not quite as
bad as that
and we should now
get it in proportion i think what's
interesting is there's a whole
population
of people who once these fears are
turned on particularly older people
they're just not too sure they want to
come out of their houses ever again
it's interesting because i think some
people who watch our show regularly
might at this point be thinking well
they've got this guy on who agrees with
their skepticism about lockdown but you
actually have a very mixed view about
the the measures the government have
taken for example one of the things i
know you talked about is the fact that
the nhs being overwhelmed would be a
just a catastrophic thing to happen
given the number of people with chronic
conditions so can you give us some some
input on that from kind of inside the
medical profession's point of view
yeah i have to say i was very frustrated
about
some of the conversation that was going
on early on where people were saying
well why do we need to protect the nhs i
mean it's just you know as as though
it's a bit like protecting shipbuilding
or you know yeah protecting you
just to be clear john francis and i were
both very much in favor of the first
lockdown and complied with it completely
it was more the later steps yeah we were
more skeptical about but please carry on
i think what a lot of people are not in
the business don't really understand is
how utterly central healthcare has
become
to the functioning of an of a modern
society in that sense it it's utterly
different i think from virtually any
other
of the activities of a modern society
and
and that's because
so many of us have got chronic
conditions
which
for our normal everyday functioning we
depend on the continual existence and
input of health services it's it's not
simply the case that health services are
there in case people are critically ill
and going to die
it's the fact that normal living depends
you know there are so many people with
diabetes with kidney problems with
hypertension blood pressure with cardiac
problems with respiratory problems with
asthma and so on and many many of these
people would have either died
or be
chronic cripples and severely disabled
in the past but now
and i'm one of them we're all of us
getting on with our lives with chronic
conditions thanks to the fact that we've
got continuous
healthcare input and if we become
particularly sick and we know that there
are people there who are going to look
after us and bail us through some acute
episodes and so on so
the prospect of happening was that if
the nhs became genuinely overwhelmed
that literally
all those activities that um
stopped happening
simply because it was the
the nhs was overwhelmed with covid
patients
then the the knock-on effects on the
whole functioning of society
was far greater i think than people
recognized it
it would have absolutely catastrophic
consequences
and also for the economy because of
course you know so many of those people
with chronic health conditions are also
productive members of the economy and
therefore if once the health system goes
down
the economy goes down as well
i think that that awareness i think that
was something that was appreciated in
the department of health and in
in the cabinet but it was something that
was
often not appreciated in the kind of
debates that were going on you know
it's very naive and simplistic to say we
either back the economy or we back
health the nhs you know which should we
back it
in a modern society that simply is is is
a meaningless kind of
um
like comparison dichotomy yeah
having said that i think of course we're
now in a very different stage so so my
own feeling as a medic and i think the
vast majority of of people with
experience of frontline
uh medicine
that we we really didn't have any
alternative but to try to protect
the nhs at that at the time at the peak
um i i think now of course we're in a
very different situation and and and
these very difficult questions of of
lockdowns versus economic and growth and
freedom and liberty and so on and that
trade-off and i think we're going to be
living with those kind of trade-offs for
the foreseeable future
hey kkk do you like music yes but only
if it's on bala like and we have
returned from successful day bear
hunting okay music must only be played
in group when we drink the blood of our
enemies well if you're interested in
rock music then elite phytrea is a band
for you they're an alternative rock band
that stand up against cancel culture and
the creeping authoritarianism in society
they're like a combination of nine inch
nails radiohead and allison chains this
sounds good we must have them headline
bear fest in russia support truly
independent music by joining their free
fan community sign up at go dot elite
fighttria dot
and get a free merch bundle that
includes an autographed photo fridge
magnet stickers guitar picks and secret
bonus gift
i mean you say we're gonna be living
with the trade-offs for the foreseeable
future and talking about death the
excess deaths
caused by the lockdown and the shutting
down of the nhs
i mean those are very very difficult
subjects and topics to address
they are and you know this is one of the
bizarre things that that struck me in in
the height of the of the pandemic and
that is
in many ways the kind of what was
happening in london was was a kind it
felt like an existential risk you know
it felt as though you know the analogy
with warfare was not ridiculous you know
but the difference was you know and i
was thinking back to
what it would have been like you know in
these very streets in the second world
war in the blitz and you know when the
whole nation is at war
the
the bizarre thing that was going on in
the pandemic is that a small number of
people many of whom were my friends and
who i was closely related to health
professionals working in
itu's and a e department it was a war
zone i mean what they were going through
watching the bodies seeing people
struggling for life working through the
night
it was a war zone but it was for a tiny
minority of people
and the vast majority of the population
was sitting on their backsides warm
well-fed safe and watching netflix
and there's this sort of strange
disconnect that
i know that just down the street there
is absolute carnage going on in the itu
and yet the vast majority of people it
has no impact at all it just simply
passes me by it has no impact on my life
and so that's a really strange
disconnect which i
and i think
some of the scars which we we're now
trying to deal with as a country are
because of that disconnect many people's
experience of the pandemic was it was
great i was at home i had watched an
awful lot of television i played some
great games you know
you know what was the problem and yet i
have some of my friends i have friends
who died as health professionals got
covered and died i have some who've been
permanently damaged and i have some who
carry
huge emotional scars because of what
they experienced and of course many many
people were bereaved and were not even
you know their last words with their
loved ones was over an ipad or a phone
you know not even able to be there to
hold a hand so there are some deep deep
scars there
and trying to come to terms with what
actually happened
and and how we can heal those wounds i
think it's going to take some time
do you think that we talk enough about
the effects that kovid had on the
medical professionals themselves i mean
i've received some messages from
doctors who said that the front line was
carnage that a lot of doctors have got
ptsd as a result yeah and
there was one and i don't know if it's
true saying that one of them actually
committed suicide as a result of what
they'd seen on the front line oh yeah
more than more than one i mean they've
been a whole number and
and and and people who are permanently
traumatized i mean particularly actually
it's the junior doctors i feel most for
because i know
you know it's as a junior you get
catapulted into
horrific situations where you feel
completely out of your depth you know at
least when you're an experienced
consultant you've been here before and
you've got some
way of understanding what's going on and
how to cope but i think you know what
happened is there were some final year
medical students who were just sort of
announced you know you thought you were
going to do your finals next year well
we we are hereby nominate you you are
now a qualified doctor and you report
for duty tomorrow and they were suddenly
you know and and watching people die and
feeling utterly
uh overwhelmed so i i think there are a
lot of stories that need to come out
and
and
it is interesting that and i and i think
a lot of health professionals feel that
the rest of of the country has just done
very well thank you
and and you know and yes it was nice
when everybody got around and clapped
hands but frankly that was
you know that was a bit trivial in terms
of
you know in wartime
it's it the instinct was we've got to
celebrate the war heroes we've got to
put up memorials we've got you know you
think of everything that goes on into
the lost soldiers
and and poppy day and celebrating the
people who gave their lives for this
country there are far more people who
have given their lives
uh and and suffered damage
um
because of of covid than than in some of
the military conflicts um certainly
since the second world war so and yet
are we going to have the same kind of
recognition celebration naming
uh one of the fascinating things of
course is that many of the health
professionals who died came from ethnic
minorities
and um
and and
were not uh
you know they they're at the absolute
bedrock of the nhs and yet again i think
there's been this sense that they
haven't been recognized or celebrated
in the way that our heroes would be
from the armed forces
do you think this whole thing is
relates very much to what you were
talking about earlier which is
th this is kind of this meme going
around on the internet like what kind of
pandemic is this that you wouldn't know
it it's happening unless you watch the
news
and that is kind of speaks to the
disconnect between the fact that the
medical professionals were on the front
line facing it everybody else i mean you
literally could have not noticed it if
you didn't turn the tv on and that's the
kind of disconnect
it is very weird isn't it because if you
think any other existential
crisis which hits
an entire nation
everybody notices it it's something
which is affecting my life and yet
extraordinarily people could have a
really nice time
um
and just let a few health professionals
get on with it do you think that the
reason for this is partly because the
people who die from this are
primarily very old people and so
it's kind of i mean this sounds very
crass but since we've got you on to talk
about this very difficult subject i'm
just going to say it like like it is
right that's very russian of you
surely
well you'll relate to me as a frontline
medic i think who had to deal with dying
children all the time but like
it's kind of factored in in our minds
yeah you know i mean these are all
people they're gonna die anyway it's not
really yeah okay my grandmother or my
great-aunt died and whatever but really
as a 30-something year old man like it's
not affecting my life that's absolutely
right no i think i think it is and you
know this is something that's really
weird about covert because
there have been lots of lethal pandemics
before and in fact i was you know 10
years ago i was part of an ethics group
that was discussing how the nhs would
cope with a lethal pandemic
but we were basing it on previous lethal
pandemics the interesting thing about
previously for pandemics is they
actually target young people
and it's young fit
people who particularly so that was true
the spanish flu it's been true of sars
it's true of ebola i mean it's often
it's young fit healthy people are the
ones who are particularly who get it
most severely and who die like flies
and that's what we were expecting and
that's part of the horror we were you
know imagining all these people 18 year
olds 21 year olds 25 year olds fit young
healthy people dying in itu how how is
society going to cope with that the
fascinating thing about covid and there
are there's a scientific reason as to
why this is it's almost completely
unique it has this very precise age
relationship it goes the risk goes up
linearly with every 10 years of age and
that's just because of something very
strange about the biology and how it
actually gets into the cells
and so that that meant this very unusual
age profile that it was almost entirely
older people and particularly once you
got into your 70s and 80s you were at
very high risk whereas the people in
their 20s as you said felt immune that's
unusual and it certainly when the next
lethal pandemic comes there's no reason
to think
it will be like that but i do think the
psychological response the way that
people responded
would have been very different if all
your mates if you knew
that all these young fit healthy people
were going down and dying and you
much more like the aids you know when i
was around when the aids
epidemic first hit and what was so awful
was it was young
healthy fit
people who were dying like flies and of
course that made a huge
huge psychological impact
in a way that that actually this because
this has been this
is largely been going on in old people's
homes and elderly people and so on has
not had the same psychological
and do you think
that reaction is wrong or do you think
it's a rational reaction
and again a difficult question i know
but this is something that i wrestle
with right
should i as a young relatively healthy
man really be that worried about cope do
you want to do that no well i do and i
think clearly because now knowing what
we know
um
you are in a very different category for
me in terms of the risks if we got
infected i mean that's just that's the
biology i mean you know as you know
there's a lot we don't know about covid
and i and i think again what the medics
are aware of is they're seeing a whole
lot of really weird stuff
people with strokes people with heart
failure people with
weird things almost every bodily system
can be affected by kovitz and again
that's new i mean
influenza and
sars and these things they're very
specific about what they hit whereas
there's something
very
interesting and unusual about coving and
so there are some horror scenarios if
you want a few horror scenarios
and one is we know that it that it
invades the central nervous system
so everybody knows that one of the
symptoms about covid is that it's you
lose your sense of smell and taste
that is proof that can only happen when
the virus has actually gone into your
central nervous system
so it is there it has invaded the
central nervous system what is it doing
there nobody knows is it possible that
it's actually going to have an impact
which comes apparent 10 20 years time
there are other examples of infections
of virus infections which only showed
neurological symptoms 20 years later
30 40 years later is it possible we're
going to have an epidemic of some weird
neurological
conditions even dementia or motor
neurone disease or multiple sclerosis
which has actually been triggered by
minor infections which people didn't
even notice i mean i don't know but i
think so before you should be sort of
too
you know relaxed about where it's not
going to affect me i think you know i as
a medic say well you sure i mean both of
us have already had covered so it's too
late we're 20 years from now
i'm already seeing the signs yeah
exactly
um
well thanks for cheering us up mate
good that's going to help me sleep
but as a result do you think we
therefore trivialize it because the
reality is we don't know the long-term
effects of it this is a new virus
therefore the people are oh it's fine i
just got sick for a week then i'm fine
now actually they're being a little bit
blase and ignorant i think they are and
there are very few doctors who are
trivializing it because we're seeing
weird stuff and which we don't
understand we're seeing
we're seeing doctors who've got long
kovids and who are got neurological
symptoms they they you know people with
they're paralyzed they can't walk
properly they've they've been
incontinent
and it's all because of coping so you
know
our knowledge is accumulating
um and in 10 years time we'll know much
better but so i i certainly think we
shouldn't be blase about this new this
new virus um but i understand why people
are i understand
and this comes back to our thinking
about death doesn't it because you know
when you're 25 and your life's ahead of
you and you know what you know i mean
death i just started to think about it
and health well i don't need to worry
about health how healthy what's the
problem
you know and so
it is possible
for people to have this
sort of completely unrealistic
understanding of
of of what's going on and what life is
like and and of the reality of of of
death and disease
so i think
again coming back to death
the thing was it until
the 50s 60s everybody saw death it
happened in your home you watched your
parents die you watched your granny and
granddad often you watch your siblings
die i mean child
mortality was huge um it was just that
was what you did and it was part of the
human condition it always was it always
will be and somewhere in the 50s and 60s
with a dramatic fall in mortality
because of improvements in healthcare
and other things and death is now
medicalized and it just happens behind
curtains it happens
and i can tell myself death doesn't
happen it doesn't exist it's yeah
theoretically i know i'm gonna die it
doesn't make any difference to me
do you think this pandemic is going to
fundamentally change our attitudes to
death
because we've spoken about it a lot
we've seen it in the news the media
death tolls the amount of people dying
all of a sudden it doesn't seem as
abstract as it used to
i i would like to believe that it will
change people's attitudes to death i
have a nasty feeling that the defense
mechanisms are so incredibly powerful
and that
as life goes back to normal and we just
say well you know well that wasn't that
weird you know let's get back to normal
living
i think people's attitudes to death need
to change but i'm not convinced the
pandemic has actually
is is going to cause that kind of sea
change
and what i'm sorry do you want to
correct well i was just going to say
that makes perfect sense to me i once
got stuck in a bulgarian airport for for
24 hours worst experience of my life and
the moment it was over i'm just i was
just like i'm never thinking about this
again
and i have a feeling that that will be
very similar with with covert to be
honest with you um but you know i was
going to ask you as a sort of counter
argument because i i hear absolutely
that the importance of not over
trivializing it but on the other hand
you talk about our failure to assess
risk and one of the big concerns for me
has been that while
we threw the kitchen everything but the
kitchen sink at covid we do seem to have
forgotten that there's other things that
cause death as well cancer heart attacks
suicides mental health depression drug
addiction all of the child abuse which
you mentioned earlier
and all of these things have obviously
exploded in the last 18 months do you
think that
we have got the right balance between
addressing those causes of mortality
well
i mean you know i have a lot of sympathy
with the politicians i mean you know
you're the only person in the country
you know i mean they're making it up as
they go along of course they are how
much training have they had for this new
brand new pandemic nobody but nobody you
know it's that famous thing you know
events do boy events you know what
what
everybody but everybody was blindsided
by this
and i think in a way that's one of the
main things
to take away and that is you have no
idea what is coming down the line
and therefore the ability to improvise
the ability to um
understand
prioritize
and and work out what's most important
it is incredibly important i think in in
a sense this is a wake-up call
arguably despite the terrible things
that have happened in the pandemic you
could say we dodged a bullet it could
have been so much worse it could have
been catastrophically worse and and
because of this weird
uh
virus it was it was very much
less bad than it could have been
and we've also seen a spectacular way in
which the medics and the scientists came
together
in order to
uh to to develop the vaccines i mean i
think that again is a story which if
you're not actually in the business you
don't realize quite how
utterly extraordinary that was and
actually very very impressive very
encouraging
that when the chips are down
and when we're facing this kind of
existential crisis and wondering whether
the human race can survive you know
where the uk plc is going to go bust
that all of a sudden
uh all the traditional rivalries all the
all the me first and the and the petty
concerns uh go on the back burner
everybody's on the same team supporting
one another i you know vicious
competitors are working together to try
and crack this problem and um
and collaborating and sharing
information and and clearing the deck
you know so that the normal bureaucracy
and the all the frustrations all of a
sudden it's gone you know whatever you
want you can have it we'll do it now you
know i'll stay up all night and do it
for you you know
so so that's again a very very
encouraging to see the way that human
beings can
respond
when faced with that kind of existential
threat
again sadly the vast majority of the
population had no awareness of that you
know sitting at home watching the
television
life goes on as normal but these
extraordinary things have been going on
[Music]
behind the scenes and um i think we
we've learned a lot but i have we got
our priorities right clearly not
i think the greatest worry is that we're
just going to go back to situation
normal
and
the opportunity i think of resetting the
opportunity of saying
can we build a better society having now
what we have learned
can we actually
taps you're making a lot of people very
tense
when you talk about resetting so what do
you mean by that what do you mean a
better society what what is it that
that's not
that you're not happy with in the way
things used to be
i think it's the rampant individualism
the
the me first the
look after number one
you know uh
the focus on self
self development self-fulfillment
um and and and the idea that
in the end the community
you know is
especially in central london i mean you
know what does it matter that there have
to be seven million other people here
i'm just getting on living my life
and i i think that is deeply broken deep
and deeply you know there's some very
deep pathology in our society in our
community
and there was just a period
at the height of the pandemic when all
of a sudden it it felt like people were
looking out for one another yes there
was it felt like the complete strangers
you know offering to help you know are
you all right you know i've never spoken
to you before but you know
we're facing death together are you all
right you okay no
and
that was an extraordinary feeling i felt
um
and it's gone
it feels like
back to situation normal and that and i
think that's that's rather sad
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns of
rock-solid network infrastructure and
incredible customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com forward
slash triggered and use our promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50 off the initial purchase
sign up for their newsletter access of
easy that tells you everything you need
to know about technology privacy and
censorship
do you think as well is because at the n
the knowledge of our own mortality
instantly humbles us
and suddenly we realize that the things
that we think are important you know the
career that whatever it may be
they're not yeah
i i think that's part of it
so the knowledge of our mortality
humbles us but it also tells us that we
depend on others i'm not i'm not this
solitary ego
other people matter
and and we're in this together
and i think it's that that combination
of things
you know and of course you don't want to
sentimentalize it there was a whole lot
of increase of crime of
you know abuse all sorts of terrible
things happening as well but nonetheless
i think many of us got a glimpse
of a better way of living
a better kind of society what it might
look like and the paradox is the only
reason it came out was because we were
under
immense threat
so going to the subject of death do you
think that we have a healthy attitude to
death in the west
and if not what would be a healthier way
to approach this subject
yeah well i
not surprisingly i think i i don't think
we have a healthier attitude to death
and i think the healthy way to is that
we have to talk about it
and we have to talk about death and
dying
about the experience of
what we've
watching other people die i mean
so i i feel in theory you know
that that dying ought to be a communal
experience you know we we need to try to
recover
this idea
that
when people are dying we need to be part
of that we need to be there with them we
need to be learning from them we need to
be sharing it we need to be talking
about it and we need to be talking about
how we would like want to die
you know it's interesting
that when you ask people how they want
to die the commonest reaction you get is
i just want to go out like a light i
want you know i want to go to bed one
day it's perfectly healthy and just die
in the bed just like that wouldn't it be
wonderful fantastic just you know bang
gone no no awareness no warnings the
fascinating thing is if you go back a
few hundred years that was universally
regarded as the most terrible way to die
really everybody agreed that sudden
unexpected death was the absolute
catastrophe
and and in fact
there's a prayer in the church of
england one of the main prayers is to
pray against sudden death because
you know so because the idea of just
being snuffed out with no warning no
possibility of saying goodbye no
possibility of preparing your next
generation no possibility of asking
forgiveness
for all the people you've you've hurt
and wounded know what possibility of
preparing yourself for whatever comes
next or you know preparing to meet your
maker or
reincarnation whatever you believe in
but just bang just what a terrible thing
to do well you know whereas
interestingly now it's seen as an ideal
way to go but i think a lot of that is
about our narcissism we're not actually
thinking about other people we're not
actually thinking about our loved ones
they're going to discover us cold
in the bed you know our children are you
know all we're thinking about is our
precious own little experiences that
that we shouldn't have anything at all
nasty or threatening or anxiety-making
so you know it's that kind of
self-preoccupation again which is which
is part of the problem but if i can push
back on you just so slightly but let's
be honest dying is [ __ ] horrible
isn't it
well it isn't it isn't fun
but
it is also
it's an immense opportunity
i mean i have seen people die and i've
seen people how it turns out
that dying has been an opportunity for
restoring relationships
for fulfilling dreams for having the
most amazing conversations they've never
had before but all kinds of positive
things that can happen
when people are dying i mean one of the
interesting things is that if you're
dying
you get a kind of relational authority
so when you're dying you can say i
haven't spoken to my we had this
terrible argument 10 years ago
and i haven't spoken them since
but actually
can you tell them that i'm dying and i
really like to talk to him
and because you're dying you have some
kind of
leverage authority
and you know
i haven't spoke to my dad for 30 years
but you know could you get a message now
in itu and i'd really like to speak to
him before i die so
dying actually is an opportunity for
healing for
exploring new things for dreaming dreams
so that was the whole vision behind
palliative care
was this idea that instead of just being
snuffed out
couldn't
you couldn't there be something precious
about those last few hours and days can
and so the motto came from the
palliative care movement was not only we
going to help you to die well
we're going to help you to live before
you die and that that was the idea that
to live before you die that actually
those final
hours days weeks months can't
turn into something incredibly precious
incredibly wonderful so
it doesn't have to be effing awful
i mean it's effing awful if if there's
nobody there if you're abandoned if
there's no care there's nobody love you
but actually time and time again i've
seen it turn into something that's
nothing wonderful
it's a very good point and do you think
that the reason you talk about making a
communal experience the reason that
often we don't do that is that we've
become these
pleasure optimizing machines almost
where the thing that we most want is to
have pleasure and the thing that we want
most want to avoid is discomfort yeah
and you see in the culture everywhere
whether it's you know we as comedians
talk about people being easily offended
or whatever like yeah we think that the
highest value
is
not to experience discomfort of any kind
whereas we really know that discomfort
is often the prelude to
the biggest transformations the biggest
growth opportunities the most positive
events in our lives have often been
preceded by
experiencing something deeply
uncomfortable yeah absolutely right now
this is very close to home for me
because i mean what you're describing is
the philosophy of utilitarianism
and that was invented by jeremy bentham
who was actually seated
on a on a chair at the entrance to
university college
london my university
because
he was a an out-and-out atheist and he
insisted he didn't believe in any of
this eternal life rubbish but he wanted
his body to be preserved
so that he
should continue to play a role in
in the university in fact it's laid down
in the university that his body
his embalmed body should be
should be present at every meetings of
the university council and it still is
although that makes sense where lenin
got his idea from
although
18 19th century embalming techniques
were not very good and after a while the
body became so disgusting they now use a
sort of plastic
replica but but it is it is still there
so the essence of utilitarianism is the
idea that the ultimate good is pleasure
and the ultimate evil is pain and
therefore as you say
pain all aspects of pain and discomfort
are deeply immoral evil and to be
avoided at all costs and it's very and
you're right that modern cultures
completely imbibe that all except to my
fascination there's one area which it
doesn't and that's the gym
because we all know
no pain no gain you know
so so in the on the sports field and in
the gym we all get the idea that
actually there is
a benefit to agony
that that real sweat and pain and
struggle
can actually be beneficial but in the
rest of our lives
utilitarianism is god you know avoid
discomfort avoid pain avoid anything
unpleasant
focus on pleasure but i think people are
waking up to this john because i don't
know how familiar with jordan peterson
and we've had him on the show a couple
of times
and i think he became a huge star
precisely by giving people this message
actually that if you want to have a
meaningful life if you don't if this
existential dread that you experience on
a daily basis by pursuing momentary
pleasures and you know the the newest
coffees and then this and that actually
by binding yourself to other people by
by uh standing up in the face of
adversity by
dealing with the discomforts that come
with the fact that you are responsible
for things and that message has actually
seemed to have really resonated with a
lot of people because i think we've just
gone so far down this uh utilitarian
path that every a lot of people are
starting to to realize it doesn't lead
anywhere that's absolutely right and
dying
as you said is the is the
prime example of that here is this
really frightening unpleasant
terrible reality
which we're all of us in different ways
called to face
and yet
astonishingly
it can be a positive experience it isn't
all lost yes there there is there is
genuine pain there is they're not just
physical pain i mean to be honest
physical pain is the easy stuff
i mean we are
these days as medics amazingly good at
controlling physical pain the problem is
there are other kinds of pain
which dying people have particularly
relational pain psychological pain
existential pain spiritual pain these
are
much harder they don't respond to uh
modern medications you know they they
they involve the real nitty-gritty of
relationships
of of
addressing reality and requiring
counseling friendship whatever it is but
they are opportunities they are
fantastic opportunities
for growth and that's why i'm not
looking forward to dying but actually
i recognize that going through that
experience myself
could be
even a strange kind of adventure you
know i've got more things to learn more
things to experience
um more things to say to other people
more things for them to say to me what
have you learned from watching people
die john
you can't summarize it in a you know
what have i learned from life it's it's
almost like that you know you you see
i've i learned that you can never
predict how people are going to face
death you know sometimes the biggest
toughest guys are the biggest wimps
and
and
the little shriveled old lady turns out
to have this astonishing
resilience
um and and character
[Music]
yeah so so it's it's an adventure do you
learn not to judge people
yeah you you don't judge people
you it's a it's an enormous privilege to
be there
you know to be there at the bedside i
just feel so many people miss out on
this experience you know it's a bit like
you know as a pediatrician i've been
there the
thousands of times when babies have been
born and that is again another of those
just great experiences of life and and
there's there's a an amazing symmetry
between that first breath and the last
breath you know that these are life
events
they are part of what it means to be
human
and they are
both terrible and wonderful do you think
sometimes that because we don't confront
the reality of our death that actually
present prevents us from living because
unless you know that it's going to come
to an end you don't realize that time is
precious i think that's absolutely right
that's the problem with denial you know
that the mechanism of denial that just
says it doesn't exist i'm not going to
think about it change the subject
actually is a it's very limiting i mean
it it keeps you at this kind of very
childish
um and and there's a sense in which you
know it's often said you don't grow up
until you've watched your parents die
and i think there's something in that
too you know that there's something
about being exposed to that and seeing
the next generation and seeing them die
that that does something to you and and
so there is an opportunity to grow and i
think you know there is a huge amount of
infantilism
in our modern society particularly if i
might say you know with a sort of
millennial generation who
who we don't like ourselves either don't
worry
i'm standing like an old grandpa
we are just on the edge of the
millennial generation and we have a lot
of bad things to say about millennials
as well so carry on
unrestricted and uncensored and
unfiltered go for it
well i think there's just a sort of
self-preoccupation and a narcissism you
know
again
the strange thing is as you get older
you hear your dad
uh saying things you think
actually you know i thought my dad was
completely
off out to lunch and mistaken and now
i've come to realize how she was not
completely human and my dad used to talk
about the impact of of the war
and the experience of being in the army
he was he was in the army during the
second world war
and and how it had changed him
and how how his life would have been
different if he hadn't gone through that
experience
and and of course you know
up until
the 60s every generation that had
experienced war
in europe there's been continuous war
for for centuries i mean the idea that
you could go without there being
major armed conflict and that it
wouldn't touch you is simply
inconceivable but now we have had peace
on
and prosperity
for what 70 80 years and and
and therefore we've grown up generations
for whom war is simply inconceivable it
simply doesn't figure
in their
setting and and and actually
that's the abnormality i think i think
no other generation
has has been so free
from war and and i think
it's not a bizarre
reality that the absence of war in some
way
because i i suspect war
similar to dying it's because
it makes you think about reality it
makes you think about what really
matters about what the ultimate meaning
of existence is and it it's possible in
this period of peace and prosperity
to be sitting on your backside playing
computer games
watching the world go by
in a kind of infantilized
existence i just want to tell the
viewers i do none of those things yeah
sure
yeah
it's that thing about good times create
weak men isn't it but i think that's
that's what you're talking about it's a
fascinating conversation um
there is one question that i really want
to ask if you no no go for it the
there's every time we address the
subject of death there's always one
topic that always comes up that again we
shy away from in this country that is
now being used the the word dignitas we
can only really use it as a punchline to
a joke
where do you stand on euthanasia
well i understand why
people
think this this is the obvious solution
um
and to that extent i sympathize with it
because
you know unfortunately one of one of the
terrible paradoxes
is that although actually britain leads
the world in terms of palliative care
and in terms of the resources we commit
to it and in terms of the expertise we
have the the terrible reality is an
awful lot of people in this country die
very badly
they die without
decent care without expert support
without the right resources why because
it is not a priority and you know
interestingly why because the great
british public doesn't think it's
particularly important because it
doesn't want to think about it
so we want to talk about we think the
nhs should be spending more money on
advanced cancer treatments we think they
should be
solving the problem of dementia we want
to spend
billions of pounds on exciting new
treatments we don't think dying is
important we don't think we should make
it a priority a lot of
the nhs doesn't even pay for it a lot of
it is paid out of people jingling
boxes and saying support your local
hospice which is
you know that we don't even provide
proper care for the dying so we will
spend billions and billions and billions
to to give someone an extra half a year
of life at the age of 80
but we won't spend money to give them a
death and dignity correct well we don't
think it's important and the great
british public doesn't think it's
because basically politicians respond to
what right
what the public think and the public do
not put pressure they put a huge amount
of pressure on when it comes to cancer
and heart disease and so on they they do
very little about death and dying so
so therefore the sad reality is even in
some of our major teaching hospitals
people die very badly
they die because doctors are poorly
trained because they're not having the
resources there's not the emphasis on it
and all the rest and so it's
understandable that people say well i've
heard these horror stories
surely the best thing to do is to have a
lethal injection or take a lethal
medicines and so on and so i understand
the motivation but i personally think
it's wrong i i because i think it short
circuits
that there are all kinds of problems one
with making killing part of what doctors
do
but
but from a personal point of view
it goes back to this utilitarianism
doesn't it i mean
euthanasia is great because i just don't
have to have any of that unpleasantness
i mean
you know as soon as i start those first
twinges i sit down take the medicine and
it's gone
so all those opportunities
for
growth for
discovery for healing for
are all short circuited do you not think
there are some cases though where
someone can't talk can't eat you know
they're in pain that cannot be treated
medically etc where they're not really
living and those opportunities aren't
there where it's the humane thing to do
to give them that option
i have to say that with
with really expert palliative care and
i've seen one you know the very best
experts doing it in the very best places
those situations are vanishingly rare
interestingly i mean i i there are
certainly rare
rare situations where it seems that
people are in such distress that nothing
can be done for them apart from just
putting them to sleep
but it is actually very rare
and it's often a question of digging
down to discover what are
what is causing the suffering and it's
very rarely physical things that are
causing the suffering people are often
in agony because of broken relationships
because of loneliness because of
lack of meaning in their lives
and therefore is the right thing to do
is just to bump them off
or could there be a better way of
helping people to
rediscover
meaning so
i i personally think that if you
legalize it
you know
there are
500 000 people a year in the uk who die
uh every year
do you know how many go to dignitas
maria it's about 50.
so the the
the it's a tiny tiny tiny proportion the
question is do we change the entire law
of the country
and therefore mean that every dying
person has to consider do i want to be
because once you legalize it you have to
give people the option
i need to tell you you got cancer you
know we can we can
support you we can prevent you suffering
we can give you
but there is always the option
we could kill you now which would you
like
once you make that option
you've really changed
uh
changed the ballpark and so the question
is for the sake of a small number of
people
do we take 500 000 people and offer them
the prospect of of killing themselves
you are a utilitarian after all
i was i was thinking and look there's
one thing that obviously we haven't
talked about that underpins a lot of
this uh i was half expecting you to whip
a bible out halfway through this yeah
because there is a a spiritual element
to all of this i think and you know
francis and i uh are not not believers
but do you think
as we've become a more secular society
some of the downstream consequences that
you've talked about are a product of
that
well it's a very complex mix isn't it i
certainly i think that um
inevitably your beliefs about
uh is there anything beyond the grave
you know it makes it makes a difference
and it makes a difference to how we
i
respond i i i as you implied i i'm a christian
i'm basically a sort of mainstream
anglican
uh
church of england christian but uh i
worked with a colleague
a pediatrician who was a card-carrying
atheist and uh
he said to me once we talked about
caring for dying babies and he said you
know
you know it is different for you and me
john because you know when you're caring
for a dying baby you're sending them to
heaven and when i'm caring for a dying
baby i'm sending them to the compost
deep
and
you know it was meant as a joke but we
both knew it was true i mean it does
make a difference and therefore if if
you do genuinely believe that
all there is is the compost heap
and that human beings are some bizarre
you know existential freak of
the universe which somehow got its
knickers in a twist and instead of doing
the normal thing it somehow went very
much very wrong and we
evolved and it's all utterly meaningless
and you know and we'll just fizzle out
well
that does
change your your attitude to
to these issues interestingly
in before christianity was a thing in
the ancient world
suicide was what was regarded as
the the most logical rational
noble way to die in many in many
cultures
and
it was really only christianity
which um
opposed suicide
because of its view that life was
precious and that all life is precious
and therefore
you know
for 20 centuries there's been a sort of
idea that suicide is not a good way to
end your life and in fact you know we
still in a very secular nhs
put enormous amount of work into suicide
prevention you know and there's a
samaritans and a huge amount of emphasis
of saying killing yourself is not a good
way to die
um
but arguably
if you follow the logic and you say
it's all
[Music]
there isn't any ultimate significance to
life there isn't anything beyond the
grave then perhaps suicide becomes
rehabilitated as
a as an irrational
way to die and so i suspect that's going
to be one of the big arguments as we
look into the future
you know what does it mean to die well
uh does it mean
[Music]
this traditional view that that dying is
part of
of life and that there are things to
learn and that it's an opportunity for
growth and so on
and for care and support
or in the end is it best to top yourself
if
my if i've decided my life is coming to
an end why not
good good night turn the interview on to
be honest with you i haven't talked this
much about dying since i was a comedian
so thank you
john it's been an absolute pleasure and
such a great conversation i think we've
both really enjoyed it we've got one
more question for you which is always
what's the one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be
whoa i i think
i think the meaning of life i i i isn't
it sad that
it's become terribly uncool
uh it's okay for students it's okay for
you know
for
people but grown-ups you don't talk
about serious stuff about the meaning of
life it's just a bit
toe-curling and cool and
i just wish we could have more honest
conversations like this
so do i it's interesting you were
talking about
the conversations people are able to
have when they're dying and really what
it made me think about is
it's fundamentally about having each
other's attention
it's about
actually listening yeah and
that's one of the things i really enjoy
about doing the show is
there's very few areas of my life even
my own life even though i do this every
day basically where i actually have the
opportunity to talk and hear someone in
this way
uh and so i suppose just having the
conversation like this gives you a bit
of an insight into what it's like when
when you have someone's attention in the
way that you might do when when you're
dying it's really interesting uh thank
you so much for coming on it's been a
pleasure the book is called dying well
that people should should look and
you've written other books as well
including about euthanasia haven't you
yeah there's a book called write to die
question mark and in fact there's a new
book coming out uh i hope next month
which uh on
on the sister dying because the you know
the assisted dying bill in the uk is a
big thing
and another book called the robot we'll
see you now which is about artificial
intelligence and the ethical issues that
ai is rising well perhaps we can have
you back to talk about that that sounds
fascinating if people want to find you
online john where's the best place to do
that so i've got a website johnwire.com
j-o-h-n-w-y-a-t dot com fantastic stuff
thank you so much for watching guys
please please please like and subscribe
and if you want to you can catch us with
another fabulous interview or raw show
always going out 7 p.m uk time 2 p.m
eastern standard take care and see you
soon
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below